i mean i cannot work i mean i'm i
remember for the longest time i just
worked from my bedroom and i'm just like
i don't know how i did that i literally
i did that for two years as well
people who can work in coffee shops to
me i can work in coffee it's like
sensory overlapping there's too much
stuff going on working on coffee there's
people doing things that yeah isn't me
and it's it's intense yeah i can't do it
i remember i tried once to edit a video
at a coffee shop and i just felt way too
like self-conscious because i'm in the
back of my head i'm thinking like these
people must think i'm so weird looking
editing a video of myself i can't i
can't i can't just treat this place like
my workstation yeah either right there's
too much stuff out there yeah it's not
it's not my [ __ ] area i can't rip a
massive five sometimes you just need to
get out of the space that you've seen
for like every day of your life
yes huh touching grass yeah yeah so yeah
you're basically touching grass except
you're just drinking coffee with a bunch
of strangers who you're never going
gonna see again how do you not just
constantly keep buying coffee
that's
you don't i just keep buying coffee
right yeah
i think that's the whole reason why
people work in coffee shops how much
coffee do you drink anyway connor
machine is [ __ ] dying it's just
good so i can buy the upgrade
no more please
i would find myself buying like eight
[ __ ] starbucks is i under the menu at
the back of my hand i'll be like a tour
guide who will come to starbucks with me
i'll be like no don't get that it's just
i i just i know i'll spend like fifty
dollars a day on coffee if i go to
starbucks and work there i know cause
like i i've i don't drink that oh i do
drink coffee see i do i drink but you
drink it so [ __ ] fast and i don't
know how like you drink like i think you
drink it extraordinarily slow just i i
think i drink it it's like you're making
love to the [ __ ] coffee i think he
drinks that at a normal place
you don't get a normal pace yeah i
story there
completely off
we're just blowing our houses and the
big bad pig came out
look i'm saying it's it's most
economically efficient to drink your
coffee and just eat your food slowly
right because you have more time to
enjoy it because because like what
happens when you finish your coffee then
you just feel like you have an empty you
feel like you have a hole because you're
like you're assuming my happiness and my
enjoyment of the meal is tied at my
speed or or the amount of time it exists
on the table it doesn't [ __ ] matter
i'm just gonna eat it that's what that's
what i like when i stop eating it the
joy is gone i don't savor the joy the
slower i take it that's absurd what are
your [ __ ] speed runner no no
but like i don't get enjoyment out of
being like having one bite and thinking
damn that's a good bite
sometimes you got her in just yeah you
don't got to say
sometimes i do but when it's starbucks
it's it's like it's like being like i'm
savoring a wipe of my ass cheek i've had
so many starbucks i'm not going to
savour it it's a [ __ ] starbucks like
i think that's why you [ __ ] drink
eight coffees a day or whatever you're
an espresso machine is a [ __ ]
battered war veteran at this point like
you just got back from what you're
watching man
i think i think i i never knew it was
possible for coffee machines to have nam
flashbacks until i saw yours i get value
out of it every time you turn on the
button it's like oh no no
not again i'm getting my mileage out of
that machine whether you like it or
not i love an espresso i i can't help it
yeah we know we know yeah i just love it
man i love the taste of dirt in my mouth
do you not like find yourself just being
like
me it's too many coffees no
why i don't know why would i i don't
know like okay so you obviously like the
taste of coffee i love the taste of
coffee okay so why not just drink decaf
no
i know this is a controversial thing to
ask but i have to make sure i have to
make sure it's just you know half of the
if the caffeine doesn't work for you
what's the difference
it does work but it's numbed but the
kick that you get when you drink it is
the same you sound like a drug
i mean i mean i
probably is i mean
i'm actually on connor's slide here
because
not regarding coffee but like for
example i like the taste of beer and
wine okay have you ever had
non-alcoholic beer oh wine
oh my gosh
it's like the coffee the what makes it
so great is that that first sip in the
morning is just beautiful like it's such
a kick
i agree and i keep getting that every
single cut
so i keep coming back every 10 minutes
is another morning
it's a never-ending morning